こんにちははじめしゃちょーで皆さん自粛2どんな音してますでしょうか
アニメとゲームのがもっと見てるんですけどもせっかくずっと家に入れるって事だっ
たら何か別のことをしてみようかなと思って今まで手を出してないとなとかよく見る
ようになってまして java の中でよくあるのが
主人公男の人によくありがちなんですけどもまたの引っ込み思案とか youtube
弾でいい
たい事が言えない主人公多いんです拾いに対して誰だよヒロインが方ピタってなった
ときとかに入っ
こういう顔するんですけどうわぁああ可愛いパワー
議題を4ちゃーんみたいなこういうのが使用ゾーンには出さないんですけども心の声
ってのがめちゃくちゃいいなと思ってちょっと今日は動画でやってみようと思います何
か僕も人といる時はあんまり思ったことを口に入るタイプじゃないんでこの際もいい歳
言葉に出さず後輩と言うところなんとなく撮ってみるんですけども
池津の心の声だけで思ったこと全部言ってみようかなと思います僕
がどんな人間かにターバンあると思って阿蘇のコーナーをずっと
あれなんでしょ突っ込みどころがいっぱいあると思うとちょっとなるべくあの現実の僕
では突っ込まず心の中で突っ込んでいければいいなと思いますでは行こうよ
[音楽]
で不二周0って一番コインでるん
えへんどう見ても視力0じゃないでしょうあなた普通に歩いてるんだよなぁなんか
シルク0な視力0するびっくりするいやこっちがビックリだよ
一定大丈夫だよコンタクトこれマジ
もう見える今今踏まずやれ
もうそれはウソでしょさすがにバトルでしょそれはきつい子じゃないんだよし
なんで良しなんでは意味がわかんない1た
明日もーぜ
あったりするんですか
3件
是非チェック
違う全図はそれそうすれば登録ですっうーん
遊べそうなぜちょっと聞き取りづらいな熱い出ればパーフェクトビッグ社もう愛的で
ないというのは辛いよ
バッハ
ヤバイ件地柄だカメラの存在一部だいたらいや大丈夫だ
[音楽]
添え快歩主義ずに出るわけないでしょ
ブーブー愛知てそんなことできるわけないだろうがせめて処分などきなさーい
ずっとするさやばいカメラの存在にバレだ
我々欲しいなぁ
住人厳選しやすいようにですですねばね
主にこと言ってやったらスーツっていた唐津っ子しくって何てないチャンスもずっ後
言ってるんですか
部屋のウソそんな記憶はあるけどずっぱ
zippo ずっとくるっていういやいや
一緒に何か伝える
偽物とはー
病気業者それは病気だよ怖い
こっちに強いよしゅっぽよちっ言っちゃうよどうしようもないわんだねー ciao 彼
らの存在はい
何なんですかこれ俺が知りたいよ
[音楽]
天井カメラ回った号
応援しますなんかしてああ
ハーン
死産同じ模様はこちられてむしろん
いやいいわけないでしょ読み込んだ時は
風に口を過いや絶対駄目だって踏み込まなかったらべてね
大丈夫なわけないでしょ
[音楽]
ダークサービスとサービス店にうんと動きだけですよね
動きて屋さんクーちゃん体幹などだと思う
[音楽]
ん
えっもっとミスっ
でた言い訳の見せたフェイスしていって言っちゃいますよなんてせこい奴なんだこいつ
薄層
ミーニャ俺が3位だったら是非がするんだよどういういくつ
1とかになったりなんだ
そこは最後まで行ってくれ
待って待って待ってる住所えっ待って x 完全に入ってる聞いてないわけないでしょ
つまらんなースマブラが一番つまらずなんでひどいこと言うな
ツバ裏最高どっちなんだよ
しています
ケッジョブ谷五月
もう無理だ
[音楽]
次は
stay
エッジ血合いねーはいさーい
います
ていた
ana
給費5てい啓発血球
ok hey
終わったどう見ても終わってるよ
[音楽]
お願いします
シェイク me
と龍堂だよ
re dl
[音楽]